from Washington DC US Secretary of
State's Mike Pompeo added fuel to a fire
half a world away we're glad that
there's a now fully formed government in
Israel as for the annexation in the West
Bank the Israelis will ultimately make
those decisions so that's an Israeli
decision and we will work closely with
them to share with them our views of
this in a private setting his comments
came two days after Israel's Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu and rival
Benin Gant's formed a national unity
government it had taken three
back-to-back elections and a year of
negotiations for the two to form a
power-sharing deal revealed on Monday
was that part of the deal included
annexing parts of the occupied West Bank
Gant's aggrieved Netanyahu could look to
extend Israeli sovereignty to Jewish
settlements with a government vote from
July the territory was captured by
Israel in the 1967 war in his under
Israeli military control annexation was
also outlined and US President Donald
Trump's peace plan for the Middle East
in January it's very clear that this is
moving forward
Israel is moving forward and it is doing
so effectively with the open support of
the United States Mahmoud Abbas
President of the Palestinian Authority
responded forcefully reminding Pompeo
and Netanyahu the land in talking about
is not theirs to determine adding if
they continue with annexation plans the
Palestinian Authority will cancel
current agreements with the US and
Israel had we told all concerned
international parties including the US
administration and the Israeli
government that we won't stand with
cross hands if Israel announced the
annexation of any parts of our lands the
United Nations has repeatedly voiced its
concern although it said it wasn't clear
if Pompeo has given Israel a green light
we have in the past expressed great
concern about possible annexation and
utilize unilateral moves that remains
our position and I do expect mr. Laden
off to take this to brief to say more on
this and
briefing this week in the Security
Council that briefing is on Thursday in
New York the Palestinians and many
countries consider Israeli West Bank
settlements to be illegal under the
Geneva Convention which bans settling on
land captured and war Israel disagrees
citing security needs and biblical and
historical connections to the land
Charlotte Palace al-jazeera